[Musica]
sono sempre rimasto affascinato e
incuriosito dalla nostra capacità come
esseri umani di prendere costantemente
cattive decisioni e avere cattivi
abitudini quando pensiamo ai nostri
soldi sembra una vera e propria capacità
innata che ci accomuna tutti
perché non risparmiamo abbastanza perché
tendiamo a spendere più di quanto
guadagniamo tendiamo a spendere per
delle cose che compriamo e poi dopo poco
tempo non se ne frega più nulla perché
non investiamo abbastanza oppure
talvolta magari investiamo troppo su
strumenti troppo rischiosi e che non
capiamo perché i soldi sono ancora
rimasti uno degli ultimi tabù che
abbiamo non sappiamo anche quando ne
parliamo con persone a noi molto care
come i parenti stretti i figli genitori
o il partner perché succede questo vi
faccio una domanda vi chiedo di alzare
la mano quanti di voi sono completamente
soddisfatti della propria situazione
finanziaria del proprio rapporto quei
soldi e pensano di prendere
costantemente decisioni corrette che non
ci sono i soldi di mezzo
bene ma platea particolarmente evoluta
ok
numeri dati e statistiche dicono
qualcosa di diverso sono gli unici
numeri che tirerò fuori nessun grafico
di borsa come vi state tranquilli tra
italiani su 10 dichiarano di non aver
dormito di notte negli ultimi sei mesi
per problemi legati ai soldi
sette italiani su dieci non investe i
propri soldi
l'ottanta per cento delle persone dei
lavoratori non sta risparmiando per la
propria pensione
il 60 per cento del patrimonio
complessivo degli italiani è investito
in immobili
e il 25 per cento del patrimonio
finanziario è liquido su conto corrente
perché succede questo
dopo una ventina d'anni di esperienza
come investitori in prima persona ea
contatto con migliaia di risparmiatori
investitori in carne e ossa
mi sono fatto un'idea
il problema principale a mio avviso che
non abbiamo ben chiaro cosa sono i soldi
cosa rappresentano i soldi cosa possiamo
raggiungere grazie ai soldi non avendo
chiaro questo ogni decisione finanziario
ogni decisione legata ai soldi
praticamente la maggior parte delle
decisioni che abbiamo anche con cui
abbiamo a che fare ogni giorno sono
viziate da questa mancata conoscenza
prima di vedere cosa sono i soldi
vediamo cosa non sono i soldi vediamo di
andare a eliminare qualche leggenda
metropolitana o falsa credenza che tutti
noi potremmo avere i soldi non sono
qualcosa di brutto e di cattivo
certamente i soldi si possono utilizzare
impiegare per qualcosa di sporco e di
cattivo i soldi si possono ottenere in
modi sporchi e cattivi truffa il raggiro
la violenza eccetera non sono i soldi ad
essere sporchi e cattivi in sé è all
origine degli stessi oppure la finalità
c'è l'utilizzo che ne facciamo sono
concetti simili ma sono in realtà
radicalmente diversi che sono da tenere
completamente separati i soldi non sono
neppure qualcosa da ostentare e da
esibire
noi come esseri umani non siamo i soldi
che possediamo e men che meno siamo i
soli che
abbiamo è che ostentiamo oggi è una cosa
che capita sempre di più il mondo dei
social network
l'esibizione una cosa costante
dell'ostentare cosa si fa o cosa sia è
una cosa assolutamente comune e siamo
umani c'è niente di male a un certo
punto di vista in tutto questo ma
attenzione perché com'è che funziona
quello sul social network e il il vicino
e si è comprato la macchina nuova io la
compra un po più potente per
dimostrargli che ho più successo
il nostro parente nostro cugino si
compra la casa nuova con due bagni
giardino io la compro con tre bagni pur
essendo in due la voglio con tre bagni è
un parco più grande su un giardino più
grande un parco proprio la piletta e che
in questo modo è davvero difficile
ottenere
mettere a frutto i soldi e avere un buon
rapporto con essi i soldi non sono
neppure da considerare come un punto di
arrivo che cos'è che succede mi sono
comprato la macchina più grande per
dimostrare al vicino che lo più successo
là fuori ci sarà sempre un calciatore
che col primo stipendio si compra due
ferrari col primo stipendio un attore
che si comprano tutta la collina è una
villa da 50 milioni non ci sarà mai un
punto di arrivo se identifichiamo
nell'acquisto nel possesso di cose la
nostra soddisfazione finanziaria perché
siamo fatti così come esseri umani ci
viene fuori un desiderio materiale
magari venuto fuori dal guardando gli
altri cerchiamo in tutti i modi di a
raggiungerlo di soddisfarlo una volta
raggiunto questa soddisfazione va a
decrescere va a decrescere non è vero
perché non è grazie di stazione è una
soddisfazione effimera
perché quindi queste false credenze
quando quando pensi ha messo di queste
false credenze queste cattive abitudini
ci sono varie motivazioni dietro
motivazioni culturali
storiche di educazione familiare e
sociologiche e varie motivazioni di
carattere psicologico e comportamentale
tendenzialmente noi come esseri umani
siamo gli stessi il nostro cervello è
uguale al cervello dei nostri antenati
di 10.000 anni fa che avevano una vita
da un certo punto di vista diversi e
molto più semplice
e i soldi non facevano parte della loro
vita
il cervello non ha fatto in tempo non fa
in tempo oggi a prendere con con
decisione con raziocino questi decenni
perché i soldi non hanno mai fatto parte
della sua vita forse fra 10 milani
saremo totalmente voluti che riusciremo
a fare bene decisioni quei soldi oggi
questo non funziona perché siamo uguali
ai nostri antenati che lei non è una
cosa come si può dire da penalizzare o
da colpevolizzare cioè siamo fatti così
siamo affatto mani con qua ci sono anche
l'emozione non qua però come esseri
umani abbiamo anche delle emozioni
questo il bello di essere umani quindi
niente da colpevolizzare su questo
vediamo ora cosa sono davvero i soldi
vediamo su cosa sono davvero i soldi del
previsto cosa non sono i soldi sono da
considerare sempre come un mezzo un
mezzo da impiegare da utilizzare insieme
ad altri risorse non strettamente
finanziarie come il tempo l'attenzione e
l'energia per raggiungere qualcos'altro
venditore qualcos'altro di più elevato e
che ha maggior valore per noi quindi
soli sempre come un mezzo mezzo per cosa
un mezzo per avere il controllo del
proprio tempo ad esempio tempo da
trascorrere in famiglia con i propri
figli tempo per prendersi un anno
sabbatico non potevo stare a casa a
capire un po cosa si vuol fare della
propria vita il tempo a differenza del
dei soldi è veramente disponibile una
quantità limitata
ognuno di noi ne ha una quantità
limitata non sa neppure con tel e quella
è i soldi teoricamente no una persona
può accumulare infinitamente a un certo
punto di vista il tempo no quindi
assolutamente consigliabile
scambiare talvolta i propri soldi in
cambio di tempo di qualità da
trascorrere per cose che ci fanno star
bene
i soldi anche come un mezzo per vivere
esperienze
spendere denaro per vivere esperienze
batte sicuramente lo spendere denaro per
acquisire accumulare degli oggetti
immaginatevi una persona che dice il
giorno più felice della mia vita è stato
nel 1995 quando in un giorno solo mi
sono comprato la fiat ritmo cabrio so
che macchine c'erano è un cellulare
nuovo il motorola startac
è difficile che vi dirà questa è una
persona vi racconterà tendenzialmente
delle esperienze il giorno più bello
della sua vita persone stato bisogno che
è nato il figlio il giorno che ha fatto
le vacanze con la famiglia il giorno in
cui magari ha portato il figlio a los
angeles a vedere una partita di basket
perché il figlio è pazzo per il basket
nba
l'esperienza spendere su denaro per
esperienze ripeto batte costantemente
spendere denaro per acquisire cose
perché le esperienze la soddisfazione di
spendere per le esperienze va a crescere
del tempo perché si creano i ricordi che
ci fanno così piacere i soldi come un
mezzo anche per la scena non per morire
per lasciato vestito per lasciare il
segno il mio occupo di finanza come
avrete intuito
i super sinisi talvolta vogliono un po
stuzzicarmi con la classica frase
i soldi non si portano nella bara
la variazione ogni tanto non voglio
essere il più ricco del cimitero
me lo dicono spesso vero ho capito che i
soldi non si portano nella bara anche se
dati a disposizione di riempirvi di
soldi nella bara poi non ci potete far
niente è vero è una brillantissima ma è
proprio questo il senso i soldi sono una
delle poche cose che possono che possono
lasciare il segno per conto nostro anche
quando non ci saremo più è una delle
poche cose che può far sopravvivere il
nostro ricordo positivo anche quando non
ci sarete più non ci saremo più quando
non ci saremo più
lasciare tutti quanti la sala del denaro
in beneficenza
lasciare un patrimonio agli eredi e
saranno contenti e vi ricorderanno con
piacere
i soldi come un mezzo anche per
per essere liberi per essere autonomi
per essere più in controllo una persona
che non è non può disporre del proprio
tempo che non è libera che dipende da
qualcuno o da qualcosa non è una persona
libera e non è felice quanto di più
diverso dalla dalla felicità i soldi
servono per preservare questa
per preservare questa libertà anche
qualora venisse attaccata
tempo da trascorrere in famiglia
esperienze di cui ci ricordiamo può
compiacere
libertà felicità a lasciare il segno e
se ben ricordate sono sicuramente cose
più importanti dei soldi cioè d'accordo
con il problema è questo che nella vita
ci sono cose ben più importanti del
denaro ma costano un sacco di soldi
una fregatura praticamente
è importante accettare questi soldi sono
importanti sono fondamentali non sono
tutto ma impattano su tutto bisogna
assolutamente riconoscere questo per
avere un rapporto migliore con più soldi
e succose nate dall'esperienza con
persone ai risparmiatori in carne e ossa
che hanno famiglia figli che piccoli che
crescono genitori che invecchiano un
lavoro hobby e che desiderano troppi
soldi vengano messi vengono investiti
vengono utilizzati per migliorare la
propria vita non per creare ulteriori
problemi perché dei soldi gestiti male
investiti male trattati male possono
creare problemi che possono peggiorare
la vita come trattare quindi i propri
soldi per migliorare la propria vita per
utilizzarli come mezzo per migliorare la
propria vita espressi darmi un solo
consiglio posso darlo solo
partiamo dall'inizio partite dall'inizio
e non dalla fine non chiedetevi
quale prodotto finanziario come devo
investire che etf che aziona che fondo
di investimento che cripto valuta
eccetera qui come questa è la fine di un
corretto processo
di gestione dei propri soldi dovete
partire dall'inizio per cosa investire e
prima ancora perché investire alla
ricerca di questi significati che
possono colorare di il valore vero il
vostro denaro perché sono il denaro è
solo denaro già non ha valore in sé ha
il valore che gli date per raggiungere
qualcosa di più elevato qualcosa che
davvero conta per voi
fate questo esercizio
ora poi per i fatelo anche
costantemente chiedetevi perché i soldi
sono importanti per me esattamente
questo in questa versione qua perché i
soldi sono importanti per me non per me
per ognuno di voi
ci saranno risposte varie da questo
punto non sono esercizi facili questi
sarà più semplice andare sull'home
banking comprare due cose a caso o
fidarsi dei consigli a caso su questi
gli esercizi giusti da fare per capire
cosa fare perché i soldi sono importanti
per me non fate una volta sola ognuno di
voi ci darà una risposta
perché mi piace essere libero faccio un
esempio così ok è già qualcosa
perché essere libero importante parte
quindi scegliamo di un livello in questa
introspezione in questa esplorazione del
significato ovvero che voi attribuite i
soldi perché vi piace essere in
controllo molto bene stiamo continuando
a scendere perché essere in controllo è
importante per te questa introspezione
che non sempre è facile da fare come
tutte le introspezioni
può essere faticoso può portare del
disagio ma è in questo modo davvero che
si capisce cosa sono i soldi e
soprattutto cosa possono fare di
importante per voi stata di allineare i
c i vostri soldi con i vostri valori e
obiettivi e quindi con ciò che conta
davvero per voi
solo in questo modo riuscirete davvero a
capire cosa sono i soldi e cosa possono
fare davvero per voi
grazie
[Applauso]